dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I say it
this paper is from 2007 from ten years
ago and I'm sure you will be surprised
by how well it is holding up to today's
standards for me it was one of the works
that foreshadowed the incredible power
of data-driven learning algorithms so
let's grab an image and cut a sizable
part out of it and try to
algorithmically fill it with data that
makes sense
removing a drunk photobombing friend
from your wedding picture or a building
blocking a beautiful view to the sea are
excellent and honestly painfully real
examples of this this problem we like to
call image completion or image in
painting but mathematically this may
sound like crazy talk who really knows
what information should be there in this
whole let alone a computer the first
question is why would we have to
synthesize all these missing details
from scratch why not start looking
around in an enormous database of
photographs and look for something
similar for instance let's unleash a
learning algorithm on 1 million images
and if we do so we could find that there
may be photographs in the database that
are from the same place but then what
about the illumination the lighting may
be different well this is an enormous
database so then we pick a photo that
was taken at a similar time of the day
and use that information and as we can
see in the results the technique works
like magic awesome
it doesn't requires user made
annotations or any sort of manual labor
these results were way way ahead of the
competition and sometimes the algorithm
proposes a set of solutions that we can
choose from the main challenge of this
solution is finding similar images
within the database and fortunately even
a trivial technique that we call nearest
neighbor search can rapidly eliminate
99.99 percent of the dissimilar images
the paper also discusses some of the
failure cases which arise mostly from
the lack of high level semantic
information for instance when we have to
finish people who
is clearly not what this technique is
meant to do unless it's a statue of a
famous person with many photographs
taken in the database good that we are
in 2017 and we know that plenty of
research groups are already working on
this and I wouldn't be surprised to see
a generative adversarial network-based
technique to pop up for this in the very
near future thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time
[Music]